yes you are a really very special person
oh my god
the biggest hospital please no see
that's just call me mike
michael they need all the help they can
get you know they need more people to
see than anybody else
okay almost done
[Music]
oh
say that one one time huh say that one
more time
you said it's about to be valentine's
day you need your hand done you got a
date for valentine's day yeah
oh man where you guys going my mother's
sister is having a um
valentine's day slash
[Music]
that's awesome it's awesome after
somebody here in l.a can get you your
hair done
right in some way you look great
[Music]
it looks great oh yeah i really didn't
think it was gonna end up good like that
it's
incredible now i wish i
waited for sure cut my ponytail off
right you were in pain though you had to
yes i said it extensions are easy you
have enough for six weeks
we didn't have to start from zero at
least
how do you feel now that this whole
ordeal is basically over
[Music]
you